it shows that elderly people still can't
play music and because that's what i'm
doing myself i'm going around touring
all the time and fantastic but it's very
nice and
it's fun i must say big congratulations
to bjorn bernie and frida agneta
fantastic
come on you're not that old they're not
that old don't do yourself down
i mean oh yeah
is that i mean why has it taken 40 years
for this to happen for for the new album
do you think
i i have no idea i was uh i mean i
recorded the first time we recorded what
1972 when people need love
and then i was
about 50 tracks i think and i play on
ring ring mamma mia waterloo i have a
dream and so on and the last two tracks
i was recording with abba was under
attack and cassandra and that was 81 and
then i thought maybe they wanted to do
new things and
they've done
done a lot of things in in sweden and
all around and
but
now they are back and for me it's
a little i i was very surprised but also
very happy and it means a lot for
swedish music because it's produced in
sweden well of course and and i mean
they're obviously pop unashamedly
populist but do you think that there was
a certain amount of perhaps sniffiness
about them when they were first out
there people you know it was perhaps a
little bit unfashionable for some people
to say they like dabber um but do you
think that that distracted from from the
the true musicality of what they were
producing
yeah they always thinking of quality and
at that time i was
i was very much involved with their
recordings and i did
i had my own career doing uh
instrumental music
and people asked me what's what do you
think about abbey do you play with abba
but i always said abba is very good and
very
high quality and
that means a lot and i think
the audience realized that and
it's fantastic they are back now and
we'll see what happens with that
the uh
avatar thing i don't know yeah the
hologram tour we've got some pictures
some pictures of how they were filming
it and they've sort of de-aged them it's
a bit odd but do you think you know they
were at the forefront of videos weren't
they they were one of the first bands to
really clock on to the fact that videos
were going to be a big thing do you
think this is going to be the future for
other bands
i mean we're living now in a very
strange time pandemic and music is not
allowed to go round maybe that's a
solution all that i don't know but uh
you know if you always have to think new
things and and develop
the situation and
technology now is
is in the hand of abba it's fantastic i
think so you never know